Guten Tag, ich bin Ahmet Demirel und der Dienstabendass und ich bin heute für Sie zuständig. Wie heißen Sie?
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Friederik.
Und Ihr Vorname?
Friederik ist mein Vorname und mein Nachname ist Russel.
Könntest du Ihre Vorname und Nachname buchen?
Friederik ist Friedrich, FP Friedrich, R. W. Richard, E. M. Doran, E. M. Richard, I. Ida und K. V. Karl.
Friederik und Russel.
Russel mit der Russel vom Elefant, also Richard, I, 2 Mal S.
Emil Ludwig, Russel.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Russel?
Ich bin 74 Jahre alt.
Und wie alt sind Sie, Generalya Geburun?
Vor am 16. Juli, 19...
Was ist das? 48? Nein, 58.
Herr Russel, was kann ich wissen?
Herr Doktor, ich habe heute Morgen ein bisschen Blut am Fuß gehabt.
Und konnte das nicht so richtig sehen, was da ist. Schmerzen habe ich keine.
Und als ich dann meinen Fuß so behohren und im Spiegel angeschaut habe, habe ich gesehen, dass da ein kleines Loch ist am Fußrand.
Und da mache ich mir jetzt Sorgen, was das ist.
Ich hatte bisher eigentlich keine Schmerzen am Fuß.
Keine Schmerzen.
Haben Sie hingefallen oder haben Sie Ihr Fuß mit Ihrem Fuß etwas gestoßen?
Ich kann mich nicht erinnern.
Also ich wohne alleine zu Hause, bisher mache ich auch vieles alleine.
Aber ich habe an sich, an den Füßen, eigentlich keine Schmerzen.
Okay. Wie fühlt sich Ihr Fuß an?
Also ich spüre gar nichts am Fuß.
Ja. Habt ihr Taubheitsgefühl oder Krübel?
Taubheitsgefühl, manchmal aber eigentlich nicht mehr.
Ich habe manchmal ein bisschen Kribbel, wenn ich laufe, dann merke ich, dass es ein bisschen kribbelt oder nachts wenn ich schlafe.
Einmal laufen und nachts?
Ja, nachts beim Schlafen.
Da hat mir mein Haushalt ein Medikament aufgeschrieben, das hat etwas geholfen, dann ist es auch etwas besser seitdem.
Was hat Ihr Haushalt geschrieben?
Ein Medikament.
Wissen Sie, der Name ist nicht?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber der Doktor meinte, dass es gegen den Nerven ganz gut ist.
Ich glaube, dass da ist irgendwas mit Garberpentin oder so ähnlich.
Wie ist der Name Ihres Haussorts?
Der Haussort ist Dr. Müller.
Okay. Garberpentin hat geschrieben.
Hat er Ihnen geholfen?
Ja, das hat schon etwas geholfen, ganz.
Sind die Beschwerden und dieses Kribbel nicht weg, aber es ist viel besser geworden.
Ich bin extra zu Ihnen gekommen, weil mein Haushalt gesagt hat, ich muss auch meine Füße achten.
Und wenn da etwas ist, soll ich mich sofort melden.
Und jetzt bin ich deswegen gleich zu Ihnen gekommen, als ich das heute Morgen bemerkt habe.
Haben Sie bei mir veränden können, am Fuß?
Nein, für mich ist der Fuß immer gleich.
Ich habe nichts gelernt.
Welchen Fuß habe ich vergessen zu fragen?
Das ist die rechte Seite.
Und wo können Sie mir zeigen und sagen?
Das ist unten am Fußballen, anseitlich am Fußballen.
Das ist so groß wie eine kleine Murmel.
Und ich habe es dann noch entstanden, habe ich gar nicht gemerkt.
Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden?
Nein, also es ist nur der Fuß, wie gesagt.
Ich habe das jetzt verbunden, weil es immer wieder etwas geblutet hat, aber Schmerzen habe ich keine.
Was haben Sie für die Schüsselfrost?
Nein, das habe ich jetzt nicht.
Okay.
Sind Ihre Beine geschwollen?
Geschwollen?
Ja, die sind immer wieder etwas dick.
Und ich habe ödeme, deswegen nehme ich auch Wassertabletten.
Aber die waren in letzter Zeit eigentlich relativ gut.
Welche Tabletten nehmen Sie?
Ich habe eine ganze Menge, Herr Doktor. Welches wollen Sie denn wissen?
Für Wassertabletten.
Achso, dann muss ich nochmal nachgucken in meine Liste.
Das nennt sich Thorazemid.
Warum haben Sie dann an Ihrem Bein? Wissen Sie es?
Ich weiß es nicht. Der Haushalt hat mir das verschrieben.
Ich kann mich jetzt nicht erinnern, wenn ich denke, das ist wegen dem Alter.
Haben Sie einen
Entschuldigung?
Nein.
Ich habe auch Stens bekommen.
Seitdem ist aber eigentlich alles ganz gut.
Deswegen bin ich auch regelmäßig beim Kabyologen.
Er sagt, dass meine, eine Klappe
beschließt mich richtig. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, welche Klappe.
Deswegen hatte mir das mit den Wassertabletten aufgeschrieben.
Dann habe ich Diabetes.
Seit ungefähr 30 Jahren.
Ich habe zu Beginn Tabletten genommen.
Jetzt zuletzt habe ich, ich glaube, 2 Tabletten und einmal 1 Insulin.
Das nennt sich, ich glaube, Metformin.
Laut meiner Liste genau Metformin 1000 Milligramm.
Ich habe dann noch,
Jardians oder Jardians, nennt sich das,
10 Milligramm.
Und ich nehme Lantus als Insulinspritze für die Nacht.
Wie viele Einheiten ist Insulin?
Insulin, ich glaube, so ungefähr 26 Einheiten.
26 Einheiten.
Metformin nehmen Sie nur einmal Produkt oder so?
Wir haben morgen eine Abends.
Und Jardians?
Ja, das ist auch nur einmal am Morgen.
Dann habe ich wohl etwas Verkalkungen in meinen Gefäßen,
also auch in den Beinen.
Und da soll ich Blutverdünnung nehmen.
Da habe ich das Klopidogre, das nehme ich einmal am Tag.
Wie viele Milligramm?
Ich glaube, das sind für 70.
Nehmen Sie noch andere Medikamente?
Ja, für meine Prostata habe ich Medikamente.
Aber Sie prostat, vergrößt Sie?
Ja, mein Urbolo gesagt, das ist halt altersentsprechend.
Das ist jetzt nicht so schlimm, aber ich muss halt öfters in der Nacht
zum Wasser lassen raus.
Dann nehme ich eine Medikamente, das ist eine Tam-Solusie.
Ja, natürlich gegen Blutdruck, klar, gegen Blutdruck nehme ich Tabletten ein.
Und so viele Medikamente, ich habe mich da vergessen.
Aber ist da eine Medikamente-Liste dabei?
Ja, hier, ich habe sie dabei, das kann ich Ihnen geben.
Ja, okay, ist sehr gut.
Aber Sie sind noch weiter wichtig?
Nein, ich bin eigentlich relativ gut eingestellt mit den Medikamenten.
Aber ich bin nur wegen dem Fuß jetzt weiter ab.
Wie ist Ihr Schlaf? Können Sie gut schlafen?
Ja, aber ich schlafe sehr wenig.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit mit den Medikamenten,
die ich um 10 Uhr ins Bett bin, um 4 Uhr wach und so 6 Stunden kann ich schlafen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masanasana oder dem Stuhlgang?
Nein, das ist eigentlich ganz gut, nachdem ich die Medikamente habe.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie in der Nacht ein paar Mal auf die 12. Gehenscht.
Ja, aber ich finde es jetzt nicht schlimm.
Ja, okay.
Reagieren Sie auf eine Medikamente oder?
Ja, ich glaube, es gibt jetzt mehrere Allergien.
Es gibt Antibiotika, die ich nicht gut vertrage.
Das heißt, Moment, wie heißt das? Amoxiclav, das habe ich nicht so gut vertragen.
Dann gibt es so ein Schmerzmedikament, das heißt, Novamin-Sulfon.
Da kriege ich immer so Allergien.
Da habe ich schon einmal sehr heftig reagiert mit Ausschlag- und Kreislaufproblemen.
Mein Haushalt hat es, wie gesagt, ich muss immer darauf aufpassen,
dass immer sage ich, irgendwo hingehe.
Wie ist das, dass ich amoxiclav allergien?
Ähnlich wie die normalgen Auflösung.
Ich kriege dann einen Yukreiz-Durchfall.
Sind Sie durchgeimpft gegen Corona und Kinderkrankheiten?
Ja, das war mir sehr wichtig.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon meine vierte Impfung bekommen.
Mein Haushalt hat mich letztendlich angerufen.
Und ich habe auch schon meine vierte Impfung bekommen.
Herr Russell, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich war mal verheiratet.
Meine Frau ist fünf Jahre verstorben.
Danke.
Und seitdem lebe ich alleine.
Und leben Sie in einer Wohnung?
Ja, ich habe meine eigene Wohnung.
Und Frau Bezirkinde, Herr Russell?
Leider nicht, wir haben keine Kinder gehabt.
Sind Sie äh, woran ist Ihr Eltern gestorben?
Meine Eltern?
Ja.
Ich glaube, sie sind sehr alt geworden.
Ich glaube, das war das Alter.
Mein Vater ist 93 Jahre alt geworden.
Meine Mutter, 89.
Die waren eigentlich relativ fit bis zum hohen Alter.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Rauchen Sie?
Bitte, ich habe Sie akustisch.
Nein, ich habe früher mal geaucht.
Wann haben Sie aufgehört mit dem Rauchen?
Ach, das ist von 40 Jahren.
Vor 40 Jahren?
Vor 40 Jahren, erzähl ich.
Das war, ich hatte mal einen sehr stressigen Job.
Und damals habe ich geraucht, aber dann habe ich aufgehört.
Was war Ihr Beruf?
Ich war Bauunternehmer.
Ich habe Baustellen gehabt.
Und das war sehr stressig.
Ja.
Und bevor Sie mit dem Rauchen aufgehört haben,
wie viel haben Sie geraucht?
Das war schon viel.
Ich glaube, das war immer mindestens 1 Schachtel am Tag.
Und wie viele Jahre?
Das Geschäft ging 10 Jahre.
Solange habe ich auch ungefähr geraucht.
Herr Rousseau, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ab und zu mal ein Gläschen Wein.
Und manchmal hier.
Herr Rousseau, nehmen Sie diese Frage.
Nicht wahrstehen, das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie bisher mit dem Rauchen Kontakt gehabt?
Rauchen?
Ja, das ist so.
Ich habe geraucht.
Wie fühlen Sie sich allgemein?
Natürlich bin ich schon sehr alt.
Ich merke, dass ich auch etwas eingeschränkt bin
in meiner Kraft, in meine Mobilität.
Aber ich fühle mich eigentlich recht fit für meinen Alter.
Ich kann alles machen.
Ich kann arbeiten im Garten.
Ich kann zu Hause meine Sachen erledigen.
So weit geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Sie können mit dem Haushaltsgut zurechtkommen?
Ja, ich mache alles noch.
Eine Putzkraft.
Die kommt alle zwei Wochen und hilft mir ein bisschen das Haus.
Und die Wohnen sauber zu halten.
Aber ansonsten versuche ich, alles alleine zu machen.
Danke.
Herr Rousseau, ich habe für Sie die wichtigste Information gesammelt.
Haben Sie Ergänzung oder Fragen?
Vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit, Herr Doktor.
Sie haben sich sehr bemüht.
Ich möchte gerne wissen, was es da am Fuß ist.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie das relativ schnell herausfinden.
Dann wäre ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Herr Rousseau, Sie haben seit der Diabetes-Militus und ein paar Konzerte.
Ich nehme an, dass Sie wegen der Diabetes am Ihren Fuß eine Wunder haben.
Aber so ist es,
dass ich mich auf Ihren Fuß angucken und durchführen kann.
Danach werde ich auch ein paar Lobottests durchführen.
Sie werden danach zum Rätgern schicken.
Nach der Ergebnisse können wir genauer schicken.
Vielen Dank.
Das machen Sie alles noch heute?
Ja.
Am Ende können wir noch mal schicken.
Wir können Sie viele stationale Aufnahmen nehmen.
Muss ich deswegen da bleiben?
Eigentlich wollte ich nicht da bleiben.
Ich wollte nach Hause gehen.
Gut, wenn Sie es für notwendig haben.
Ihre Gesundheit ist jetzt die wichtigste, denke ich.
Am Ende können wir noch mal sprechen.
Vielen Dank.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Ansonsten gehen wir in die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Dann können wir die Fragen am Ende besprechen.
Bitte schön.
Herr Arzt, machen Sie es?
Guten Tag.
Guten Tag Herr Erwarz.
Wir haben einen neuen Patent aufgenommen.
Jetzt möchte ich Ihnen vorstellen.
Haben Sie Kurzzeit für mich?
Ja, für Sie doch immer.
Bitte schön.
Der Patent heißt Friederik Russel.
74 Jahre alt.
Ich habe vergessen, die Gröschen und die Fragen.
Der Patent ist 1,75 kg und wiegt 96 kg.
Wie groß ist der Patent?
1,75 cm.
Der Patent ist 96 kg.
Wie groß ist der Patent?
Nicht Patent, sondern Patient.
Ja, Patient.
1,75 m.
Russel.
Der Patent ist Reitner.
Der Patent hat beim Bauunternehmen gearbeitet.
Und verwidert hat keine Kinder.
Der Patent hat am rechten Fuß eine Ofenerwunde.
Der Patent hat es heute Morgen bemerkt.
Er war deswegen beim Hausarzt.
Sein Hausarzt hat den Patent zu uns geschickt.
Den Patent zu uns geschickt?
Ja, zu uns geschickt.
Der Ampus hat den Patent gefühlt und gerieben.
Besonders beim Schlafen.
Der Hausarzt heißt Dr. Müller.
Der Hausarzt hat den Patent gegenkrippen und totalpreisgefühlt.
Der Patient hat keine Schmerzen.
Der Patent hat eine Schmerz.
Der Patient hat seit 30 Jahren Diabetesmultus.
Er hat mit Metformis 1.000 mg.
Und Korotens 1 mg.
Und Caridians 4 r d e n c e.
Der Patient hat 7 mg.
Der Patient hat vor 10 Jahren Herzinfarkt.
Der Patient ist unter Kontrolle beim Cardiologen.
Der Patient hat keine Schmerzen.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerz.
Der Patient hat eine Prostatik.
Der Patient hat eine Diuretik.
Die Patient reagiert auf Amoxin und Novaminallergie.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerz.
Der Patient hat eine Diabetesmultus.
Der Patient hat eine Knochenbeteiligung.
Der Patient hat eine Verkalkung der Gefäße.
Der Patient hat eine Prostatik.
Der Patient hat eine Diabetesmultus.
Der Patient hat eine Polyneuropathie.